[Music]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here in my tiny corner of
nowhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
they stay because of all the things they
can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an Easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him
I'm talking about two life-and-death
stuff the Oasis the world's most
important economic resource
there's nothing less than a war for
control over the future welcome to the
rebellion wait
[Music]
like many of you I only came here to
escape
[Music]
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight help us save
the Oasis
[Applause]
it's weird you like hanging out with
animals more than people yeah well
animals get me a rescue George from here
was 2 years old George never would have
survived on his own he definitely trusts
you last night
George was seven feet away 500 pounds
George okay buddy
you're scared it's okay this morning is
nine feet pushing a thousand
what's happening to my friend are you
familiar with genetic editing the
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hell of a day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's a big
mistake I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago
George didn't ask for this they're gonna
put them down
that's not happening
there's something in the river
I was just thinking the only thing
that's missing right now is the giant
crocodile my father always told me just
survival is never certain
and when there are no more leaders to
follow
you must become one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey this is yours
most important thing keep your finger
off the trigger at all times unless you
need to shoot somebody when that happens
till you run dry
keep your eyes open every cop in the
country is gonna be looking for us
big Nick original gangsta cop in the
flesh
watch italic for dead six on the way to
the hospital Peggy he's a bad guy I'm
gonna make you a deal give me the names
of all the guys who got away
I'll get your medic I ain't no snitch yo
he's dying son we got a problem it's a
major crime get to know your enemy boys
every big-time crew has been busted
these are the guys who took him down by
magician
simulator no need to fix you could yeah
we're doing sand flats we're trading up
the Federal Reserve it's like Fort Knox
at any one time there's anywhere between
500 and 800 billion dollars in there
every millimeter of a covered by cameras
sensors and motion detectors 10 across
the street and stare at the building for
two minutes that's security on your ass
the bank has never been robbed
[Music]
you know just means means I am a member
of a gang only we have badges which
means you are done look like the types
from arrests you know our cadets either
put you in handcuffs drag it down to the
station we just shoot you
you're not the bad guys
we are saying like the whole city go
against me
I'm Molly bloom do you know about me
this is a true story
you ran a games in LA for roughly eight
years yeah then you ran a games in New
York for Russia - I don't run a game in
over two years not to spoil the ending
but that's when the government raided my
game and took all of my money assuming
all of it was made illegally which it
wasn't in this room you couldn't buy
your win the baller you couldn't buy me
then you couldn't buy a seat at the
table
when we saw it athletes written as
that's just the tip of the iceberg
you're not taking a percentage of the
pot no keep it that way because you
don't break the law when you're breaking
the law breaking the law we're able to
find out for sure
aren't we laws are written down yeah I
mean is any way about your book in life
right I did you spent eight years buying
the world's most exclusive glamorous and
decadent mancave for the office
guarantee the publisher has certain
elements and I could get you a million
and a half what kind of elements I
passed
I'm just curious as to why you passed on
what would appear to be the only way out
you have it have these real names
creative differences the law that I'm
accused of breaking the plans gambling
is betting on games of chance yes
suckers in a game of chance pokers a
game of skill why does he wanna know at
22 has a gold-plated resume why did she
run for games risk is nuts you're gonna
get blown up
you got 2.8 million on the streak right
now that money should be in your hands
just how deep into the Russian mob where
you
new offer on the table completely we
hand over Audra you seen what's on those
hard drives family slides careers will
be ruling why are you in this alone
whenever the people you're protecting by
not setting the whole story it's not
their names I'm protecting charlie my
helmet wash
because it's nice dear Aunt Lucy you
sent me to London to find a home I have
a wonderful family both you're in great
shape for a man your age mr. Brown Wow
Thank You Paddington hang on how old do
you think I am
Oh Oh 80 and I really got to grips with
how things work Mr Gruber
come in I'd like to get my Aunt Lucy a
birthday present how about these ruling
shoes please Mr Gruber be serious
what's this this happy book is the only
one of its kind and they want a lot of
money pouring I'm going to get a job and
buy that book no window cleaner
Oh
[Music]
cheerio come hold it right there
oh but I'm not the thief we're rich
again round Hey
laundry duty it's only one red sock
what's the worst that can happen
afternoon chaps I want to hear all about
the investigation Paddington is innocent
he's a master of disguise well this is
breaking and entering haven't broken
anything
[Applause]
you think you're going there
Paddington looks for the good in all of
us and somehow he finds it if we're kind
and polite the world will be right
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we're taking game night up a
notch oh boy someone in this room is
going to be taken and it's gonna be up
to you to find them it's a murder
mystery party whoever finds the victim
wins the grand prize you're not gonna
know what's real and what's fake wait a
second can't just come in here and break
the door though
guys make sure you get a piece of this
cheese it's just one that follows just
sucks okay Roger dad you drive safe I've
always enjoyed the camaraderie of good
friends competing in games of chance and
skill to revalue it seems like Ryan you
go first I'm scared
[Music]
it's not a joke
people are in real danger
[Music]
so much worse
stop wait me I have kids at home not
with an ass like yet you don't oh well
thank you
oh no he died his instructions on how to
remove a bullet she didn't have rubbing
alcohol so I got you this lovely shark
good idea way to pivot and then a
squeaky toy for the pain
[Music]
most of us ride this train every day
we not we say hello but how much do we
really know about each other it's my
first time on a commuter train I'm sorry
if we met no I'm Joanna Michael what if
I asked you to do something I could
profile the effects of individual on
this train
I don't understand it's just one little
thing someone on this train does not
belong all you have to do is find them
why would I do it in the bathroom there
are 75 thousand dollars that money is
yours if you do this one little thing
I thought this was hypothetical you'd
have until next stop to decide what kind
of person are you
Michael Michael McCauley they're
watching you I am NOT gonna do this look
outside southeast corner don't make me
hurt someone you love
I don't want to have something it's all
over the news there's a witness was it
deep with the wrong kind of people
if I might have to fight someone honest
Ryan's gonna kill him
what do you know
you have no idea who you're up against
I'm done playing games
[Music]
now everyone dies
I'm not gonna let them hurt you
she was trying to set me up we have a
hostage situation take them out
you stop this train now
I asked you to do one little thing can
you describe its full no stop from the
beginning what do you think I do when
you're away you think I'm out in the
garden pining looking up at the sky your
husband's here let me see him
he's extremely ill you have to tell me
where he was what he was doing it was
his decision to go in it's something
they termed the shimmer
we've sent in drones and teams of people
but nothing comes back but something has
you're a biologist you served in the
military if I knew what happened I
didn't save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking cities states
you need to know what's inside
it's beautiful check this out
looks like they're stuck in a continuous
rotation are they understand they're no
sharks uptake like that not possible you
can't cross very different species yes
well soldiers on the last expedition
seemed like crazy or something here kill
them
something's come to the face you're the
fence
we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroyed
it's making something new
[Music]
medical marijuana is already a
multibillion-dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this look most people will tell
you Buzz Aldrin walked on the moon
and even a complete idiot will tell you
Neil Armstrong did it first and do you
know why he went first dishes hatch open
and hiss because he pushed bezel and the
[ __ ] out of the way and sees history but
a ballsack I'm satisfied
[Laughter]
[Music]
look man you're in some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy dude then cash
pool no I'm saying you're poor poor
tomorrow you can apply to Mexico what we
want you to hand-deliver the weed pill
formula to the lab I'm not supposed to
touch the minibar but I'm going to do it
you know I don't even care anyone doing
it that having the [ __ ] cry-baby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out in a
jiffy
I sold a little product to the cartels
but when we cut them off they got a
little angry I know a guy I'll track
down dictators if I can find a guy in
the middle management what do they want
injected a microchip okay I need to keep
track II can't scare me
details of the big bad cartels no things
work not in Mexico there's Harold Harold
Oh bingo
you really believe in God because I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in God I guess I kind of do
but not things you just have to get
better for you
trust me I have good instincts the world
is a mysterious place there are marvels
of nature just waiting to be discovered
by those who are daring enough to look
mara was like the creature I had only
heard existed in legend a mythical
monster strict out of your worst
nightmares with wild eyes and a hideous
face and feet that were amazingly
freakishly
creature with perfect white teeth then
breath it just smells all minty fresh
and only hair that has on its entire
vine is on the top oh you're scaring up
hey don't be scared it's look it's just
a story everyone knows that the small
foot isn't real or is it
[Music]
oh that's nice real nice way to scarm
for life
[Music]
[Music]
working for the man
[Music]
you cup not exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how are you I'm Mary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning wife
[Music]
this is great look out your window why
I'm taking you away for the weekend I
just can't believe this is my life that
I get to live with you
buzzes huh
it meant nothing to me before you can a
great office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor I bought it for us I
should have asked you first
oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo
the architect this location is perfect
I'm going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
grey I'll pick you up of five that may
not be done by then
because we are
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
so you want to play yes sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her
to comfort you in times of need and to
keep you safe first long as we both
shall live
for over a century the hotel has been
his life
next summer
anyone
[Music]
yeah so impressive it's like a hotel on
the water
oh no Bobby's gonna puke we're running
out of time you've seen what's happening
out there
a lot
[Music]
[Music]
I can handle Thomas I can show up
eventually that's what I'm afraid of
it took you because you're immune to a
plague that's wiping out the human race
I think you're worth sacrificing to find
a cure
remember stop stop that the last city
Ricketts the whole base of operations
mr. Lyons dinner bottle - people are
going 3 years we spent behind wolves
trying to break out now we're trying to
break back in I guess shotgun
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it to regret what are
you just hosting I did what I thought
was right
there's no guarantee we make you back
fees don't we stop this together as well
I'll end it that way too
[Music]
you still care about it down here cool
item eight come on
annotates believe the roundup torture
kill when how does it stop it stops only
find a cure
[Music]
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
[Music]
please do you ever feel weird weird
sometimes I feel like I'm always on the
outside there's this invisible line that
I have to cross to really be a part of
everything and I just can't ever cross
it me too
my name's Simon I'm just like you except
I have one huge ass secret I like I said
I like your boots
goodbye nobody knows I'm gay sometimes I
feel like I'm stuck on a ferris wheel
[Music]
one minute I'm on top of the world
[Music]
in the next cement rock-bottom
I've been thinking about why I haven't
come out yet maybe part of me wants to
hold on to who I've always been
just a little longer
[Music]
this
[Music]
no matter what announcing who you are to
the world is pretty terrifying because
what if the world doesn't like you
[Music]
PS doesn't seem fair that only gay
people have to come out by straight to
default I have something I need to tell
you I like girls he's trying to cute me
I like man I'm straight
Romeo and Juliet are moving to a whole
new garden all clear
not quite perfect but it's ours think of
all the adventures we're gonna have okay
it was me
oh man Katie that is just are you done
minute to coogee humans coming purges
everyone they were supposed to live
happily ever after
but when their world is in danger
Julia the noobs taroko there's only one
known to call and Sherlock knows sworn
protector of garden nose you mean except
for the one you literally just broke
[Music]
can't anyone hear this but we have to
get across that River you need a ship no
[ __ ] Sherlock
you've got a great unknown hey our next
clue is in the park directions quickly
just follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red Suns
MacAvoy and we block to Attila Jeff for
mary j blige and Johnny Depp with
original music by Elton John and Bernie
Taupin
you have to go him to come out let's go
to forward hold Oh forgive me I've never
been the back end of a swirl before
Orlov knows that's not how a squirrel
fixit's behind mankini can you
demonstrate Julie you see yes they're
acting like a rear-end
[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off it'll dig just feed
it like it owes you money we're gonna
get a little damp or yellow snow here we
mix that with just another little dab of
our baby white now well that's just
dancin happy little C I remember this is
your world you get to make and break the
rules here sweet baby Jesus wish I could
jump in there and roll around and all
that cascading white powder yeah just
get high and all of life's splendor God
I love cocaine so much
holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a kite
right now okay
let's paint in a few little happy trees
there nothing wrong with making friends
with trees no what you don't want to do
is eat these paints trust me on this one
all right I'm gonna walk off from Ken
that's right that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams wet and remember hugs
not drugs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take off your dress when I was in Moscow
they heard about a program
young officers drink to seduce and
manipulate to use their bodies
use everything color sparrows that's
what she is
[Music]
what's your name Laura surname Croft
Barrett your father's gone you could
pick up where he left off I see so much
of him in you
pregnant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tune called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop them
I promise I think I know where my dad
went that's right in the middle of the
devil sea it will be an adventure death
isn't 100 an adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did
[Music]
what do you know about my father
now I see the likeness so recklessness
close the to once and for the fate of
humanity is now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days the
world has gone bloody mad I'll take two
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky
yeah but I have never seen anything like
this
how much more you hiding
[Music]
we are home
[Music]
my son it is your time
my respected
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze never face
[Music]
not be televised
[Music]
in
because we don't know
cuz we young young I waited my entire
life for this the world's gonna start
over i'ma burn it all
[Music]
what happens now
it demands what happens to the rest of
the world
[Music]
[Music]
snacks come into a clock gentlemen thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
once you begin to discover who you are
then you really realize how you have
been given authority over your life
but you can only do that through the
struggle of life and
go for boarding
[Music]
[Applause]
when you're working on a dream at some
point in time a transition takes place
[Music]
you start challenging this
[Music]
nothing in you but
taking shortcuts
[Music]
I don't know man you ever just feel like
life it's just pushing us towards
something like some greater purpose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well look at you may your dreams bring
you peace
now this is just funny it's not bad or
good
that part's up to you
I don't mean to be rude I supposed to
know you actually me we just met
of the
beep
it's harsh world strong prey on the weak
down here
yeah
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human
thank you whatever I had to you for you
I'd give you whatever I have
I'd give you my heart Alida they will
come for you
why
I think you're someone very special
mais de
[Music]
of the
[Music]
I have a dream a song to see I'm so glad
you're here I'm pregnant
but I don't know how to do this by
myself your mother is the bravest person
we ever made goodbye baby
let me tell you how she did it all on
her own
[Music]
life is short the world is wide
I want to make some memories
this dress might look very pretty on you
you don't know me at all do you
[Music]
I think we should stay here together I
wish I could stay here too
turns out he's engaged I hate it when
they do that I was cheated by you and I
think you know when look at me now will
I ever learn
I don't know how but I suddenly lose
control there's a fire within my soul
[Music]
never felt closer to my mom she wasn't
scared because she had me
we can't tell anybody else about the
baby okay
I just told bill and I told Harry I told
many many people let's get the party
started
grandma you weren't invited that's the
best kind of party little girl generous
honest pure graceful creatures you know
what that was never of work no pants you
must be right
wait did you try to eat me show me your
teeth do like a go bug it was you how
are you so good to see you
I don't think of one thing Mickey stop
our fun
[Music]
hello
[Music]
new neighbor I'll explain it to him
we'll share our land around here hello
I'm Bea these gates are incredibly
sturdy I just need to keep the wildlife
out where they belong
they're angels this is their place okay
so he's tricked her
there's only one way out of this he's
got a go his face was so classic I have
a vermin problem an electric pencil
keeper now stop look away we can't give
up it's our only suits there
[Music]
you're mine rabbit
oh wait - boys guess you're alone
nothing could make me happier
I got into this you're gonna fix it
I think our daughters are friends I
think it makes us friends I'm hunter my
Julie Mitchell kills hero I can't
believe it's Rob they're so grown up my
daughter anymore boobs no we don't
understand what they're saying so it's
not new puzzles and teenage emoji
eggplants are dicks all emojis have a
secret meaning so like trees are we and
this thing is your queen so she's gonna
get Rosie Kip and then touch his dick
eggplant good rule come out of the
smiling face that's jizz stand down it
is
this is a sex act they're planning on
losing their virginity on prom night I
mean it's not sex they're saying hey
you're okay with me you're okay baby
[ __ ] new our girls are not thinking
things through I'm gonna stop him I'm in
let's [ __ ] block those [ __ ]
this is our last big night together
this pack just gonna make snot even more
perfect WWV dee dee what would Vin
Diesel do
[Music]
in times of crisis parents are known to
have superhuman strength
so messed up did your dad try to stop
you when you wanted to lose your
virginity was too busy high-fiving
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about a little chugging contests
bringing home that westward but
chuckling you got this dog
no I'm tagging out you're in what you
put a baby everything's looser down
there a baby out of my butt on the count
of three I am tripping so hard I just
had a vision
my dad was chugging beer it was [ __ ]
[Music]
how would you define terrorism
[Music]
the current definition is any individual
or group then uses violence to achieve
political goal
the administration believes that the
drug cartels fit that definition
[Music]
you want to see this thing through I'm
gonna have to get dirty turning you
loose on those new rules this time
[Music]
[Music]
help us start a war with hope
[Music]
everyone suena morning say four five we
gotta talk about what's happening in
Chicago
everybody's watching this viral video
this guy in a hoodie - call him - Grim
Reaper stop the carjacking is he right
for taking the law into his own hands
he's become a folk hero what about the
shooter like a white dude the men who
did it are out there so there's nothing
that you can do is that what you're
saying if a man really wants to protect
forces and want to buy a gun he has to
do it for himself
I believe you Joe you're not gonna kill
me no
jackass
you got caught in some crossfire dice
the ice-cream man can't walk to school
if they don't work for me will you
your last customer you're cocked locked
and ready to work I'll say they called
him a guardian angel oops my life
[Music]
you look much better
getting out socializing hmm not so much
well whatever you're doing keep it up
okay I will
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people who need help with matters that
can't be explained come to me these
hauntings can be terrifying things I
should know I had faced many evils in my
life this was different though the
haunted house it's my family's house if
we can find out what it is we can stop
this curse to end this evil I need to go
deeper into the further
I don't have memories from this place I
have scars I'm gonna find it and I'm
gonna finish it
please there's someone right in front of
you I don't see anything the japanese
archipelago' 20 years in the future
canine saturation has reached epidemic
proportions an outbreak of dog flu rips
through the city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exile calm the Isle of
Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage
same here words on my mouth nobody's
giving up around here and don't you
forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief we're a pack of scary
indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi you heroically hijacked a
junior turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to
the islands because of your dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him the
little pilot why should I
because he's a 12 year old boy dogs love
those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog it's gonna be
a fight
[Music]
or somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
[Music]
Christmas Eve time mystery
[Music]
expectations who knows what might happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
time has come
[Music]
I have this reoccurring dream I feel the
warmth of the Sun on my skin and the
comfort of arms around me and I want to
stay there forever but that would be
impossible I have a severe sensitivity
to sunlight doctor appointments became a
part of my routine it's not gonna fall
into remission and every year the risk
becomes more serious so I spend all my
time indoors behind special windows
sleeping during the day and staying up
all night and playing music every chance
I get
Hey what should I have said hey I'm
Katie Price
I've watched outside my window for the
past 10 years that I've been in love
with you stalking you every minute this
is about Taylor Swift does she has
awkward interactions with boys and then
she just writes amazing songs about it I
don't understand how we've never met
I've probably skated by your house every
day on the way to practice hey you
wouldn't want to do something sometime
would you I'm really busy during the day
but I could be free at night what does
Katie price want to do there's so many
things I want to do taking me in first
live show
[Applause]
so that was literally one of the best
things that are right I'll be a German
to the dead you coming
I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer being someone more than
just a disease this isn't something you
can just not tell me I'm so sorry but
we're not the couple who doesn't try
[Music]
[Music]
my whole life's to steal so uh what are
you dating like an accountant now Ellen
ventriloquist stop ha you love a dummy
this is not why we're here
[Music]
I know why we're here a rescue Amish
save the dinosaurs from Island that's
about to explode what could go wrong
blue is alive you raised her do these
animals deserve the same protections
given to other species or should they
just be left to die these creatures were
here before us
if we're not careful they're gonna be
here after
[Music]
life cannot be contained life breaks
free life finds away
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon my Scotia as you know
parole is a privilege it's a mistake but
it happened and if I were to be released
I would um I would just want the simple
life I just want to hold down a job make
some friends yeah pay my bills even if
this was possible it made 20 people
seven people why do you need to do this
because that's what I'm gonna how long
would it take you to make seven pieces
of jewelry if I were a parent how long
if I told you you didn't have to live
with your mother anymore
it's me the one it was quite bad
which man named wall which real name
eight-ball what if we could make all
this go away
in pairs as well sorry okay being with
my family I told him having a garage let
me tell you how big of John Knowles I'm
out I take the chocolate I'll be back
before you know can I come with you
this is mommy's very special work trip
for three and a half weeks then that
will be hosting its annual ball and we
are going to Robin not the ball itself
the neck of Daphne Kluger valued at over
a hundred million dollars revenge
it's a - fun do not run a job in a job
[Music]
there's can't we just go to this debate
to steal stuff yes is it genetic or the
whole family like this that early
[Music]
just a little bit more hopped up for
Doug and his best friend Han na every
day was great
moody Barry mr. roat coming hunting
today wouldn't miss it for the world
and every night was a party until the
day everything changed
through the badlands the edge of stone
is over long live the edge of bronze
how are we gonna get our Valley back
[Music]
let's again commit
[Music]
we challenge the champions a caveman
caveman you took a hope
if we win you leave my tribe in peace
what an idea
you think you can beat Rael bronzy oh I
can help if we play this game and beat
them at it we can have our Valley back
what happens if you kick the ball in the
goal then other men hug and kiss you
I'll give it a go you're losers caveman
always I've been always will be
[Music]
if we work together we may just stand a
chance
we still a try
[Applause]
no we always hunt rabbits couldn't we
try hunting something bigger
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormally
yes
last question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why your year
[Music]
what is this place she's in hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
you've been through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
close your eyes
see with mine
[Music]
you are a top student but look at you
now you can't keep using your father's
disappearance as an excuse to act out is
that his work well that's it about their
dad he wanted to touch the Stars imagine
that the abbe here wants to get to her
other hand as quickest option is to walk
across the street but it turns out a
straight line is not the shortest
distance between two points not if you
use a fifth dimension it's outside of
the rules we know of time and space aunt
arrives my hand instantaneous so you
fall space more likely wrinkle it
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find it we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light of the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by an
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop it
is you be a warrior
my love is always there even if you
can't see it
[Music]
I trust you
[Music]
the most important thing a man can take
into combat it's a reason why we're in
this fight boy she marked my words
19 men attacked our country the 12 of
you will be the first ones to fight back
it's us we're going in you know I love
you right I would be remiss if I did not
say to you even in success the odds of
you coming home you're a hundred percent
sir we're coming
[Music]
why is none follow you you take me to
Taliban are you ok with psychosis he's
serious
who's written before anyone can't kill
the spring-break just prefer hey this is
we [ __ ]
[Music]
50,000 okay to apply to us and yours
just an army of 12 we've just been
handed the most important mission in the
free world
hold on our boys are gonna ride into
battle on horseback chances are we are
not going to make it out of this one
equipped now what happened back home it
happen again and again yeah
each you got to make this decision
nothing I'd rather do I'm in thought
you'd never ask
[Music]
where the hell do those come from
take out biggest guns first
my neighbor bigs good cap the only way
home is winning
this is from the towers you carry that
with you it's gargantuan seven storage
structure with no apparent rhyme or
reason
each maze of halls more confusing than
the next it's under never-ending
construction
it was built on the orders of a grieving
widow
Sarah Winchester is the majority
shareholder of the Winchester Repeating
Arms Company who would want to take it
away from her worried about her sanity
dr. price do you believe in ghosts
Stockton I do not believe in anything I
cannot see or study
[Music]
[Music]
I can feel it in the air in the walls
this spirit has a power we've not seen
before it has found us
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the wall we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from we believed in you and who did it
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
my ball
Lara
they evolve
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that is London
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right there to fail all the same
read it
run from it Destiny's still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
and gates our defenses
and get this manner shift
[Music]
on isn't something one considers
imbalancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
who the hell are you guys
[Music]
[Music]